this is a production of Cornell
University yes no I I'll I'll be brief
uh but yeah it's it's my pleasure to to
introduce the topic today being
presented by star Sage Greg and and
Matthew uh they've been you know working
with the Innovation lab for crop
Improvement I've been um really kind of
been engaged in interacting with them uh
since the start of the program you know
one of the state goals of of the
Innovation lab for crop Improvement is
to develop tools Technologies and
methodologies uh for crop Improvement in
my experience you know developing these
tools Technologies and methodologies is
is relatively straightforward but
developing uh you know these ttms that
are actually adopted and have real
meaningful impact in a breeding program
is is incredibly diff uh difficult and
being able to really track the impact
that these tools are having can be
really uh you know a challenging
Endeavor especially when dealing with
with you know large and complex research
you know organizations like a lot of the
Nars that we partnering with with ilce
and it's been great working with uh this
team because they're they're bringing a
lot of expertise that that we don't
really have uh certainly in the plant
breedings and genetic section um they've
they've been able to put together some
great surveys that help us get a better
understanding on you know really how
these these programs operate what some
of these baselines are and this is
really just incredibly important
information as we try and actually
develop collaborations that are going to
be impactful with these organizations
and try and track and learn from you
know how these tools are being used in
the programs and so with that I I just
uh like to thank everyone for for
presenting today and I'm really looking
forward to this presentation thank you
okay thank you so much Kylie yeah all
right
so a quick outline say
Greg myself is going to have three parts
of today's presentation we'll talk a
little bit of complex objective of this
service and then we'll give you uh two
overviews the methodologies and some the
fundings from the two the surveys
actually or I was going to put three
surveys and I don't think there's enough
time and tomorrow I'm going to present
that in the live meeting with Kylie and
GS lab and I will cover my recent uh
interviews with our the area objective
uh leads okay so today only the two
service and at the end uh we'll share
some the learnings and then also mainly
for discussion very informal and then
under 10 your questions I think for
ourselves uh we are planning the next
phase of the grand proposal so allow to
learn from the discussion as well okay
so the quick
begin so CG and the Nars uh is the main
uh topic today we are going to speak you
may Wonder uh as
Coronel uh Community why we care about
CGS why we care about
Nars in the developing uh world uh these
a large this is the largest uh public uh
breeding programs Agriculture and funded
by many uh funders and so important
important because since the Green
Revolution in the
1960s the uh solving the hunger and even
in today in terms of managing the
climate change uh so this has a huge
impact it's not only from The Innovation
perspective also in terms of adoption on
the farms field and this is great model
has the large Footprints over hundreds
hundreds uh countries and the Coronel
and the USDA we are one of the 3,000
Partners so for The Graduate students
you are here your research your
publication even your future as your
different opportunity to work in
industry or academic or funding agencies
one way the other because you're in
plant breeding imp plant science you'll
be in this value chin somewhere so
that's why uh so many people we know
uncom work with cgir and
Nars so you can see here uh 15 centers
they are formed over uh since uh the
Green Revolution over time and sometimes
there were 17 18 and some sometimes 13
to right now active 13 centers they lead
agriculture innovation technology
transfer to small holders uh in the
developing world so they mainly serve
this is not really for the very
profitable main yield like large
multinational know huge inputs that's
also caus today's climate uh change
challenges so the small stakeholders
meeting the local uh nutrition and also
diet and equality this huge impact as a
model in addition
to uh
well we we learn from them so this is
one recent from the last two to three
years uh the genetic innovation from CG
the pipeline from the left to the right
first part is product design to figure
out what Farmers what Le customers what
type of products they need and this
involve Economist Market intelligence
together looking at from the end
beginning with the end for local a
adaptation to help design and going to
either the center part as the the GM
Bank of prebreeding
and then go to the breeding networks
breeding networks uh they may cost uh
from uh original breeding crosses U go
with population development and early
testing late testing all the way until
un Farm trail testing okay so this
itself can take depends on the crops can
last somewhere from four to eight years
before they hunt up to the seed systems
uh in the product delivery in the
variety registration Etc
so this is a little background from uh
the CG perspective they work in the
broader network with the Nars so I'm
going to pass this on to a sage and then
I will come back when we talk about the
second part of survey so with that Sage
please amute yourself thanks great thank
you star so as mentioned I'm Sage I'm a
research support specialist at the Tata
Cornel Institute for agriculture and
nutrition I'm joined today by my
colleague Greg Traxler who is a Tata
Cornell fellow also working on the feed
the future Innovation lab for crop
Improvement or what we call ilce um so
we're both members of the ilc
institutional capacity research team and
so just to know we're mostly a group of
economists um so we're really excited to
present some of our preliminary results
um and ideas with this group of plant
breeder plant breeding researchers um
and Greg will be available for questions
as uh when we get to the Q&A session so
I'm going to start by just giving a
background of ILY which is hosted here
at Cornell ilsy aims to advance crop
Improvement programs in developing
countries by facilitating Global
Communication through a network of
experts in National agricultural
research systems or Nars in US
universities prioritizing gender and
youth inclusivity nutrition Market
relevance and crop resilience 's
designed to support Nars to set breeding
priorities and adopt modern Technologies
and plant breeding research Regional
centers of innovation in east west and
South Africa Latin America in the
Caribbean enable the Nars to collaborate
and share resources the project focuses
on Orphan crops that are relevant to
local diets and adapted to environmental
conditions so the Tata Cornell Institute
is tasked with measuring the change in
institutional capacity of partner Nars
as a result of the ilc project um next
slide please
so so here I'm showing the simple theory
of change us University scientist
compres the Upstream research areas in
genomics phenomics breeding informatics
and priority setting and then with the
objective areas of research there are
tools Technologies and methodologies
what we call ttms that are passed onto
Nars through various trainings and
workshops with the expressed outcomes of
increasing the rate of genetic gain to
an impact economic growth resilience and
nutritional development goals next slide
please so this is a little bit of a more
in-depth framework for the LC project uh
the LC priority setting objective areas
working with Nars to implement various
studies to better understand and
incorporate stakeholder input to create
product profiles the trait Discovery
team is tasked with translating those
product profiles into feasible breeding
objectives employing hypothesis testing
experimental design the genomics
phenomics and breeding informatics team
have a more direct impact on the
Breeders equation components and
labeling breeding programs to employee
Technologies to reduce cycle time um and
streamline the breeding process
ultimately leading to genetic gain so
LC's philosophy suggests that if Target
population needs are optimally
understood through effective priority
setting in integrating gender equality
youth engagement nutrition and
resilience varieties will be adopted
effectively thereby meeting their
intended impact on
livelihoods next slide
please so by serving the Nars Partners
we want to better understand the crop
Improvement system um we also wanted to
know which modern ttms are being used in
which breeding programs um and by
identifying capacity gaps we could
better understand the strengths and
needs of institutions in individual
breeding programs and then lastly
monitoring capacity changes over time
enable the team to understand which ilc
interventions have an impact on capacity
next slide
please so to come up with the metrics
and a survey tool to measure
institutional capacity the team first
conducted a comprehensive scoping review
of the literature to Define
institutional capacity in the context of
plant breeding we did we identified 74
papers that assess the various
components that make up institutional
capacity and this helped us create a
list of indicators we then reviewed
existing capacity assessment tools like
the bat which was used in the CG system
to identify and adapt relevant metrics
to the LC context this led to various
discussions with experts in the field
including ilc objective area leaders
enabling the team to arrive at this
initial list of survey questions we
conducted a deli among experts and
stakeholders to generate a consensus on
our list of questions and then using
this list of questions separated into
indicator areas the team conducted pilot
survey with 14 iasap breeding programs
in Africa and Asia to test the
functionality and Technical features of
the survey and also to receive some
feedback from the programs concerning
the quality of the instrument we then
went back with all the feedback and
simplified the tool and reduce questions
to eliminate redundancies and streamline
the survey finally we conducted the
survey to measure the Baseline capacity
of 18 Nars breeding programs involved in
the LC project next
slide so on the left shows the
components of capacity that were
identified in our literature review um
including the various resources
available to a program management and
planning collaborative activities
breeding activities setting priorities
and stakeholder involvement these
components were translated into our
indicat areas for the survey as seen on
the right and in each indicator area
represents a module in the survey each
containing about 10 to 15 questions next
slide
please so we surveyed the nine uh ilc
Nars partners with a total of 18
breeding programs in Africa and Latin
America uh the program surveyed we're
working with crops including cow peas
sorum millets common bean and sweet
potato next slide
please so on the left you can see that
about 30% of breeding program surveyed
did not make any crosses in 2019 and
only 6% made more than 100 crosses so
most programs made in between one and a
100 cross loses in
2019 and then the graph on the right
shows variety release over a three-year
period of the programs that reported to
release varieties we can see almost 15
50% did not release any varieties in
2017 to 2019 so only 34% release three
or more varieties over that threeyear
period corresponding to an average of
one variety per year next slide
please so as for the use of modern
technology we first looked to the
digitization of data where we found just
over half of the programs surveyed did
not collect any phenotypic data
digitally at the field level while 27%
of the programs collected 50 to 100% of
phenotypic data digitally the right
table shows the percentage of programs
that use breeding management software
for various breeding activities um so
using software for trial designs or
trait data were the most common while
very few programs use breeding
management software Ware for genomic
data on the bottom left graph um shows
some of the more modern techniques to
achieve greater genetic gains and we can
see that half of the programs use
genomic Services a third use genomic
assisted selection uh sorry a third used
marker assisted selection and less than
a quarter used genomic selection so
since achieving genetic gains is the
express goal of the LC project we then
asked Nars if they measure genetic gain
and learned that just 11% of the
programs that were surveyed do measure
genetic
gain next slide
please so as I described earlier
resource availability comprises an
important part of institutional capacity
like the availability of scientific
staff and genetic resources and we
learned about 60% of the Nars surveyed
have less than three full-time
equivalent staff available to their
programs and most of the programs have
less than 500 accessions available to
them for comparison I'm displaying the
data from our pilot survey with iasap
breeding programs where most of them
reported to have greater than 1500
accessions
available um next slide
please so some things that we learned is
that there's high heterogenity within
the Nars and this should be considered
when targeting ttms that will be most
appropriate based on the Nars capacity
so most Nars were making less than 100
crosses released less than an average in
one variety per year and had a small
number scientific staff and genetic
resources available to them at this
level of plant breeding research there's
a smaller probability to enhance rates
of genetic gain so in contrast there are
a few programs that were surveyed that
are reporting to use modern techniques
conduct many crosses and have more
available
resources next slide
please a large component of an
Institutional capacity is the policies
in place that determine the funding
allocated to each program which impacts
the availability of resources so orphan
crops comprise a smaller proportion of
Institutions budgets compared to other
crops given that there's these
institutional constraints in the state
of breeding programs um within the state
of breeding and many of these programs
that we surveyed that I was describing
earlier it may be best to adapt capacity
building efforts to ensure that Nars
breeding programs are testing and
releasing varieties more effectively so
that could mean targeting TTM as
collecting and analyzing stakeholder
input to generate product profiles more
accurate phenotyping data management and
experimental design then the programs
that have a higher level of capacity
will be better candidates for targeted
training of these more advanced genomic
type
ttms next slide
please and then lastly tools like our
survey to monitor capacity can be
helpful in the decision-making process
to better understand each program and
adapt ttms appropriately
um so just a little background that we
will actually do the same survey at the
end of the project in this upcoming year
to measure that change in capacity so we
can track those changes over time using
this survey and very few Nars are
measuring genetic gain variety turnover
adoption or yield gains in Farmers
fields and these are really important
measures of progress and to track the
actual impact on plant breeding efforts
so um this is a consideration of what we
might want to quantify in the future
um so I'm going to now hand this over to
Star again to talk about some of the
studies that she's been
conducting thank you okay thank you so
much uh Sage I know she run through very
fast uh many of you may have questions
if there's just one quick burning
question we can also save some time at
the end
anyone okay if not I'm going to switch
to the second gear all right so this is
on the CG the other ones on Le two
completely independent survey so this
survey was conducted in the first uh uh
three quarters of 2022 the context of
this survey is with the one CZ means the
15 centers there are similar crop
breeding programs across different
centers and the one C uh was uh for them
to work together as these large
companies located in different parts of
the world uh with this centers have very
limited bi informatics resources
including the institutional
capacity uh servers and data management
systems also their staticians or
quantive genetics Etc in this context
the thinking is if all the bi
informaticians quantive genetics they
work together with the covid mode people
can work online and can provide services
support to the centers the regions they
do not have the resources in the data
analysis uh in the decision support ex
and this survey uh with this in the mind
uh there was also transitional uh in
terms of people from accellence breeding
to the breeding resources and genetic uh
uh Innovation this new funding like as a
project the new program so yali uh she
took the position Kylie was before as
the module five leader in ACC brief Mee
and she lied about Matrix and
informatics so I worked with her as the
program manager managing all the uh B
informaticians qu genetics across all
the centers and while this funding
tration the module three lead the
genotyping the Service Tool manager Ina
and also Ardo who's the module two lead
from ACC breeding to together uh uh you
module five the four of us in this
transition stage we're trying to
understand from all the breeding program
perspective are they ready if we have a
centralized service and also what are
the key common demands if they are ready
so that's the
background so as I mentioned there are
two overarching goals the first one on
the life hand side is are they ready and
then from technical perspective also
psychological willingness to how
everyone work together the second one is
the common demands if they are ready
what type of capabilities they need for
these quantitive genetics about
information to provide so the survey had
a total eight
pieces and I'm going to get into more
details later so in the next several
slides I'm going to talk uh about uh the
methodologies we used also uh some the
results and some discussion about the
Insight so these all together in these
two uh overall arching goals so the
first part is
uh for social scientist I think many of
you already know a sample sides to
collect this type of uh priority setting
and then for us Stanfield we were
learning uh who do we send a survey to
uh the data is going to really indicate
truly the program will they need rather
than diluted so with a lot of back and
forth the four of us thinking and the
way agreed with the different CG leads
is we only send it to the head of the
breeding program so they can work
themselves and distribute if needed and
this need to be really representing how
the weight uh from what they need
instead of we sent to everyone that's
why highly selected one survey sent to
each person with personal email we wrote
describing the background why this is
important and also time to turn around
access individual service sent to Nar
breeding sorry Nar n CG uh breeding head
and it turned out uh some of them
answered themselves and they also
allocated uh to their uh subject matter
expert for the parts of the questions
they are the best expert answer we sent
to the 12 Nars breeding head and six
responded and among total 2 five uh
respondents they represent 16 different
crops and 12
centers and this is the overview for the
all the cgir people who answered so you
can see the center affiliation and the
crops uh they represent and the once
highlighted in red they come in
answering this survey with the manager
role looking at this big picture and the
other one UNH highlighted they are
almost like a lead breeders representing
their entire
program and uh we have 89% responses
rate and 200 almost 40 participant rate
because some the centers uh they have
multiple subject matter expert answered
the
questions so from Nars
interesting we sent to 12 reading head
but only uh six responded so we can
discuss later why we couldn't accomplish
the same participation so here is a 50%
participation and then uh the full
respect I'm not listing the other six we
invited but didn't uh didn't answer the
survey and hopefully this also represent
the 50% of the Nars breeding programs
need as
well hide
this so the first question as I
mentioned overarching go on the left
hand side we want to know is uh are they
technically ready to measure the
institutional capacity uh we want to
Define what's called institution
capacity right so capacity including uh
Technical and human capital resources J
plasm Etc together collectively are they
able to do the program uh quickly and in
good quality to meeting the demands and
the mandates so this how we Define as in
institution capacity so first we want to
understand are they ready if we want to
provide the centralized services so from
here I don't know you can see very well
uh but overall we want to ask them very
similar these two independent study as a
sages and we all thinking good has think
about the same thing we ask them for
phenotypic data or Pig data genotype
data and the breeding crosses these
different type of data are they already
captured in digital format if they a
digital format they are shared in
centralized servers then these
biometricians can sit somewhere analyze
their data together and distribute the
results and that would give more power
right so we want to ask them are they
digitalized or they are just doing on
their own computer or on piece of paper
Etc so 75% of the reading head of the
particip they mentioned they are ready
they already have these in digital
format and the phenotype data mostly
digital types followed by genotyping
data and pigr data and lastly is the
process this means Sops how things make
transation from one person hand one
stage gate to another so that's least
digitized and here I want to point out
is uh B the data how you really get
inside is not only you collect data
because this is harder to to see what
that that mean right so we ranked and we
also developed a method to look at is
called sum of product as the indicator
to look at this uh with more inside
basically the degree of data digital
tyes measured as a percent data
collected and also stored in the digital
formats and then you can see the phot
type data when they run as low like say
0 to 33% mid 34 to 66% High means 67 to
100 % data already in the digital format
and when you multiply the data uh level
for each one ranked by the the cons and
you sum that up called sum of product
this is as one indicator and with this
uh you can more easily simply compare
them so you can see the breeding process
only 40% 46% digitzed with the highest
at phenotypic data so that um also um
match with what we see in Sage survey as
well another thing we asked them about
infrastructure do they have the
infrastructure cloud or server and are
they ready even they have the
infrastructure to share uh they are
ready to use the data analytic services
so when we ask these questions uh just
very simple for them to read as one to
five so the current state uh Readiness
were qualitatively a size at a low
medium high or as one two three or one
125 from one's lowest five is high this
is qualitative it just gives some
indication is not directly quantify
their right in is but overall you can
see uh the ones on the right uh side
infrastructure actually they are pretty
good uh for most of them and the five is
the highest here and the inter read is
uh actually mod four and five they are
ready they want to have the centralized
uh analytical
support uh one is the server another one
is the data management also the
management practices are they willing
right so we ask them about currently do
you have your data just dispersed means
on your local or they are like a hybrid
you have some centralized on Cloud
Server or purely centralized server so
what we see is in the three means the
centralized 24% and large majority 64%
still on their local computer these uh
definitely making sense you can see very
diverse differences and the 24% program
they are technically U more ready to
adopt this centralized services so
tradition into the next part is in the
goal to the second goal is about if we
are ready for centralized uh analytic uh
function to support them then what kind
of capabilities do they need from the
phenotypic genotypic bio informatics and
data management all full functional area
we ask them uh the features they want to
have as must have or should have could
have or will not have so the must have
means
non-negotiable and should how is
important and if uh but not adding
significant VI and could have means nice
to have but if we leave out have small
impact we now have means not at this
time frame is important so we ask them
to put these uh uh capabilities uh in
these buckets and we also assign a
numerical value 4 3 to one for each of
the category this allow us to quantify
the final demand and also fund out the
priority ranking in the capabilities so
you can see this is just one example in
term of data collection after collecting
you do data curation and data analysis
decision support in these four
functional area what do they consider as
uh must have and based on the count the
frequency distribution you can see
uh this is way for us to quantify it uh
so the demand calculated not only with
the must should could and will not have
uh we also did a summer product very
similar like early on I showed you in
the previous Slide the readings uh for
each category the ranking multiply by
the number of accounts and you do the
sum this give you a cumulative number
easy for you to compare them and then to
simplify here you can see the decision
support is the last stage of the
breeding analytic to provide for product
advancement consider is in the highest
demand vers is data analysis and the low
is the data collection basically they
are saying they can take care of the
data collection on their own but they
need a support of for decision support
and then uh you can also see uh for the
must have should have and will not have
some Cent have a little bit uh diverse
wheels for example for data collection
uh for one Center they think this is
very important ex and data
curation so for phenotypic analysis what
kind of capabilities they need they
agreed on based on the analysis here is
uh optimize the trails the design and
also the product advancement basically
there is not much difference you can see
the points and the relatively lower at
the end uh is like for some program for
example I think should have is a side
selection here and then for some program
they want to have the variety catalog
drone plasm catalog to compare drone
plasm and then for two of them consider
very important but vot like R by other
Pro people participating in this that's
why at the end is as lower ranking
that's the phenotypic and how about for
micro selection using mid or low density
genotyping based analytics and we see I
think Gary atan if he see this recording
he will be happy he always talk about
calcul the grm the yeah the grm this
rise up showing this the highest in
demand and followed by the P
rication so for me the high density
genotyping here is the genomic selection
of gas come in place we can see gas
considered not important for the
breeding program instead predicting the
breeding crosses to go to their proing
block considered the highest importance
and followed by predicting
gbvs and the third function is the bi
informatics in terms of capabilities
infrastructure we can see uh provided
infrastructure that's what very timely
they need and then followed by merging
data from different sources including
phenotype pedigree genotype EXC and
across the different actors merging them
together that's what currently uh
repeatedly saying in the seventh eighth
section of the survey the eighth uh part
of the section survey is about how the
data flow integrate together so that
allow them working holistically from the
pipeline A to Z and here it talk about
the digitized processes this come in is
very obvious and also centralized
databases so that they can share with
programs in different regions okay so uh
this the main
results and then here the summary
already mentioned Uh u based on their
ranking the common High demands uh for
the second part of a goal we understand
and uh uh with these high demands now we
have to ask about the way how the
Personnel the quantitive genetics or the
B informaticians to provide all these uh
capabilities in high demands are we able
to give them the product of services and
that's the story uh actually uh continue
to be discussed but at least now we
understand breeding programs what they
need and then uh key learnings there are
many many learnings uh for myself uh
through doing this uh with the the 1cg
breeding informatics team uh tech
technical Readiness considered really
important uh they have digitized data
processes centralized data storage for
sharing and then from here from Cy part
you can see as well increase uh the
investment this uh uh uniformally from
both Nars and CG Center we need this to
enable them uh to do the centralized
data sharing and the common demands the
money but in order to provide this
minimum viable products have to be uh
focused on as well that's where the
phase currently uh we origin wanted to
build that but that didn't take off
there are a lot of factors we can
discuss offline and then but so many
learnings how to make this ready for the
early adopter as you can see some the
program uh 24% have the data management
ready and for them different stages of
the tools they need for example making
the breeding
cres uh at very early on and then very
diverse programs sometimes uh even
though you have this high
demand when you go to talk to Le
breeding leas from different centers
they do not want to give away their own
bform or work together support
centralized because
time of the year different capabilities
needed so the resources and how to have
tailor the support and solving this
bottl neck one at a time so with that I
think uh sage and also Greg uh we can
just open up uh for the questions and
especially uh in the context of planning
the next steps uh with LC and um I think
there's some good news when CG Nar just
got a the new commitment for the next
two to three years almost like 900
Millions that's what I heard just two
days ago and hopefully the the second
part of survey we have to pause and also
from uh the people here uh on the line
and also here to see how we can be part
of this value chin as a service provider
or as the stakeholder you see you can
contribute yeah so I'm going to uh open
up uh for the uh questions uh because we
have a few minutes and uh also just want
to give big shout out uh to the LC the
area uh objective area lead uh I did a
focus the group interviews uh recently
not enough time to cover today and
tomorrow in the live meeting I'm going
to cover also thank you so much
uh uh Sage Greg and also Matthew uh for
collaboratively recently we are planning
the ongoing survey yeah okay so I see
um people on the line
okay so yeah marjerie
please is there any do you have any
ideas of how to increase the engagement
from the Nars and their particip ation
in the surveys or is there have you
noticed any specific reason why the CGS
are more responsive than the
Nars yeah I think sage and then Greg
also add comments as well from my part I
knew we sent exactly the same
personalized email from our side the
lead one to one to the breeding lead
from Nars as well I think just lies uh
direct working relationship maybe maybe
v a spam folder maybe uh they didn't see
the importance so it's so important we
are very selective and also have the
personal connection to reach the
awareness
yeah stage Greg from y surveys uh you
may also have the struggle about getting
people's uh engagement participating
right especially the data
yeah sure um yeah that would that could
be a bit of a struggle our advantage is
that we're all working on a project
together um that are receiving funding
uh from the same source so there was a
little bit more of a Buy in from the
Nars we were surveying because they were
part of this project already um so you
know we all represent different teams um
but we have tried to survey other
programs um you know both in the CG and
the the Nars and we've had difficulty
getting people to respond at times um so
yeah these are things we're constantly
thinking about how to get people to buy
into this idea that institutional
capacity is a um a valuable thing to
measure and track um and so that's you
know doing presentations and trying to
to talk to more people and I think these
personal connections make the big
difference um we've had some responses
based on you know knowing some of the
Nars from this program and then asking
them to ask some of the breeding
programs within their institution
themselves so um yeah this kind of
collaborative network is really
useful yeah okay there's one question
from Kylie on the line Kylie is asking
uh the surveys self assessment versus
this external evaluation like a bad uh
any sense how well the self assessment
external assessment
align
so there must be some part align and
some part um may may not so so align
because
uh from some yeah go ahead Greg yes star
thank you we we did include in our
survey uh subjective questions of the
scientists how well do you think you're
doing in particular areas what's your
subjective opinion on your capacity in
data management or given areas and then
we also collected objective data so we
do have um both kind of the you know the
counts of number of crosses
and access to materials Etc and then can
come compare those to the scientists
expressed opinions about their capacity
so we I don't think that we've p those
out to compare them but we could do
that and just to add on a little bit
something that we had done in our
research effort is we visited some of
the breeding programs um and did some
field work there and with those programs
we conducted a midline assessment and
that was the major goal there is to
validate some of our findings um which
had changed a little bit you know some
we found that you know one program that
had claimed to be doing marker assisted
selection when we pass them in person um
they they didn't they weren't actually
implementing that or you know maybe they
had markers available but they weren't
um using them for selection so there can
be um you know some some inaccuracies
with this uh but continuously monitoring
over time has and going in person has
helped um clarify some of those and help
us to explain the questions um and
ensure we're getting more reliable data
based on how we pose the
questions yeah just want to add
that
actually the right questions to ask and
also really uh designer question is more
than half of the the survey research
itself because what you get from the
answers largely depend on how you ask
this question so definitely it's really
good complementation for onside visit to
the external uh evaluation
because uh even for example uh the
answer they answered like read from one
to five uh level right if the breeding
programs located in so in so many places
there is a huge hyrogen it's difficult
to how just one number to read it even
the breeding lead think they are ready
or they already at a highest level so we
cannot really Overlook the
diversity the whole hydrogenous of these
programs so this just quantitive simple
way to C quick look uh yes I'm wondering
how centralization of reading analytics
um tools might affect the capacity
building um of young scientists at Nars
or um yeah other breeding um Specialists
working at the Nars and I'm wondering if
that came up in a survey at all and do
you think that would affect willing to
move to this model um of centralized
Services um for example um if there's
young scientist or students working with
these Nars Partners who are um wanting
to learn genomic prediction or wanting
to learn database
management yeah this definitely uh is
going to be more difficult for the Nars
than for the
CGS and then for the young scientists I
think the model is uh these onside visit
haathon and then even during Co this
team work online together the community
building we had one platform called
breeding informatic uh analytics uh
platform so people online are join in
different functional areas and then they
have different levels some very Advanced
and some just beginning and also they
compliment each other some knows python
some knows art very well so actually I
see
even for Coral University and for other
LC
Partners we provide a huge value in this
system as well so for example we have
the uh the Nars Partners recently
visiting from Costa Rica in ice group
for several weeks and then also the one
from uh Sy go as well so they uh they
are learning and then the university
like us provide huge value and then also
The Graduate students right because the
Publications from The Faculty here and
we are you guys are at the front end so
a lot of the learning here for you to
dive into some the case studies working
with them this could be a one model
because Le uh a young jior uh bi
informaticians some of them uh finished
the master degree and then some of them
actually pursuing and after they find
opportunity they leave from where they
work they come to us do PhD study we
lose people over and over by working
with them and it's very difficult for
the team there to hire because where
they are located sometime no electricity
no internet and then they are asked to
do this to do that is not really easy so
more
centralized uh
resources for them to continue even like
seminar like this allow them continue
learning when they get a stock the other
is uh the infrastructure so this
platform is huge to how this is not only
Social Capital to boost the morale for
them to work learning informally in this
platform is huge so may not be easy for
the supervisor to say centralized
because they have a lot to do but in the
uh the effectiveness the collaboration
Partnership of a great Val
yeah sorry I don't know this long
answer okay can I just jump in there for
a minute star because I think that's a
key question I think that if you were to
kind of separate the individual human
capital the kind of quality of
scientists in the National programs and
compare it to 20 years
ago uh it's it's pretty clear that the
scient individual scientists are better
trained but but if you would compare the
institutional capacity to deliver
genetic
gain uh within Nars compared to 20 years
ago I think you would have a much more
mixed
picture uh it's not at all clear that
the Nars today
are stronger in their capacity to
deliver than they were 20 years
ago uh the picture that emerges is
they're not releasing more varieties
they're not doing more crosses than they
were in the
past uh the if
you again separate out the quality of
the scientists that are in staff in the
CG and in the Nars better trained uh the
individual scientists within the Nars
have great incentives to build their
human capital and then move on move on
to another build their career not
necessarily within the Nars move to the
CG or some other
institution uh and so as institutions
the national programs are very
unstable funding uh is is not secure uh
resources are not necessarily growing we
have very poor measures of those um and
the CG has been incredibly unstable over
the last
decade uh so I I think it's very
important to look at developing some
measures of institutional capacity and
stability uh keeping in mind that
uh capacity of individuals is is an
important component but it is not always
going to solve the institutional
stability problem and lead to more
effective delivery of genetic
gain yeah thanks uh Greg for that
addition the huge challenge is the yeah
how do they really the problem so much
greater than yeah the resources they
have it's very difficult to do what they
asked to do with uh three full-time
people and maybe they do not have the
expertise and they need to have the
resources in infrastructure Etc and then
people work in Nars Le National level I
think they are only at maybe onethird of
one quarter of the salary as the the
same like say classmate who went to work
at the cgir
scientist
so gping maybe the last question and we
I can stay for other people a question
maybe sage grg and stay as well last
question yeah yeah U okay uh so you done
the survey I don't know what's your best
plan
you
the feedback to different
institution
what's yeah you have the surve
have I
guess goal is of the service are to give
some feedback to the different Institute
right right so my part of survey I can
speak to the say and great answer to
that part so my part survey after we
finished we shared the results with uh
the key leadership right that's the
justification uh these the
functionalities we need to put together
this the priority and then to build this
uh one
centralized analytic Services prioritize
which one to go and that's where we left
with and then this may we even brought
out uh analytic team together
in in Egypt and that's what we did at
the planning face by face what
functionality we focus on the components
in the matrices serving this entire
pipeline so this is one thing internally
deliver these a minimum viable
implementation connect with databases so
with uh the like say braby or data Lake
connecting between the different
databases with the functionalities they
asking this is one thing another thing
is uh the first part of the go one part
of survey I didn't present but this is
also asking the breeding program are you
willing to contribute and what
percentage of the budget to support the
centralized uh analytic services and
support and each of the service support
we have them as an service have other
number just like your other genotyping
uh you have a price this may have price
or this maybe just as a service as a
support this come from the breeding
budget but they don't have to pay for so
this where we were trying to move onto
the new operational model that's the
survey background and we didn't GA there
because the funding as some of you
already aware and um hopefully new
phases in 24 different story just can
continue building this so how about for
sage Greg would you like to add did you
hear ging's question after the survey
where do you take to the next stage do
you give back to the participants of the
survey why don't you go ahead
Sage sure um so our plan at the moment
again we're conducting the kind of same
measurements at the end of this project
so we took this the initial Baseline
survey in 2020 um the first thing that
we did is we shared a lot of these
results with the ilc objective areas um
and so that we could provide kind of
this Baseline information so they knew
within their kind of relevant metrics um
where the the breeding programs were at
that they were working with um and so
this upcoming year when we take these
measurements again the plan is to have
different um kind of reports available
and we'll meet individually with the
breeding program leads and whoever can
join the call um and give some some
survey feedback um another thing like I
mentioned we we've been visiting a lot
of the breeding programs so so far we
visited uh four of them um with the plan
to visit in this next year three more um
so that's an opportunity for us to give
some feedback and talk about these um
and then hopefully you know this is
still up in the air but if there's you
know another um another cycle of this
project this could be involved in the
planning process um you know moving
forward how to take these kind of gaps
in institutional capacity and really
plan for um you know the next five
years yeah and we've also shared our
results with the national
programs to to allow them to place their
own program in context of pure
programs so they can kind of see who's
who's doing what who's using what what
capacities exist within other
Nars yeah and also just by working with
sage and Greg Matthew the last several
months we are still uh collecting um
basically we have ongoing survey and in
January when I go to pack we continue
collect data from the yeah the
participants and these uh insights is
going to help us to uh plan the next
phase is about matching the demand with
the supply and identify opportunities
and the challenges where and also if you
do customize the support at in indidual
uh Center or the stages level so this
give us this as a foundation to be more
tailored for next
phase
okay all right thank you so much I
really uh appreciate by working this
semester and then answer the survey from
The Graduate School or from the course
for evaluation and how great our final
yeah thanks thank you everyone online
have a good day thank you everyone
pleasure thank you so much sage
and this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu